bonjour patrick mignola je vais tomber
une des voix qui compte dans la majorité
présidentielle et ceux président
emmanuel macron on l'entendait dans le
journal qui donne une longue interview
la presse quotidienne régionale c'est la
première fois qu'il s'exprime depuis la
présidentielle et il annonce la création
je cite d'un conseil national de la
refondation alors c'est une référence
assumée au conseil national de la
résistance qu'on avait connue après
guerre est-ce que la situation est aussi
grave qu'en 1945 pour prévoir une telle
un tel conseil aujourd'hui
oui je crois qu'il nous reste une
semaine pour convaincre les français que
le scrutin de dimanche prochain est un
scrutin important précisément pour ça on
est au lendemain
d'une grande crise sanitaire
international avec toutes les
conséquences qu'elle nous a fait vivre
on est en plein dans une guerre qu est
aux portes de l'europe évidemment il
faut que faut qu'on reconstruise ce pays
et donc c'est évidemment pas le
mouvement démocrate que je dirige
l'assemblée nationale qui dira vers souk
irait à l'encontre d'une initiative qui
rassemble à la fois des politiques les
acteurs économiques les acteurs
syndicaux les acteurs de terrain les
territoires de la tour était favorable à
la démocratie locale à ce que les corps
intermédiaires reviennent dans la
discussion est dans l'action politique
et donc je crois que c'est une heureuse
initiative mais dans le choix des mots
patrick mignola il ya une dramatisation
qui a assumé conseil national de laroque
fondation c'est encore une fois ce jeu
reprend d'ailleurs une question qui est
posée au président est ce que c'est un
clin d'oeil à cette histoire qui encore
une fois été dramatique est ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans cette situation
dramatique
pour vous que je lui tenais à vous vous
croyez pas que la démocratie française
est malade et les élections ça garde ma
chronique sélection nationale en de
malades emmanuel macron il faut qu'on
prenne notre part de responsabilité mais
je pense qu'on doit tous prendre une
part de responsabilité sur les trente
dernières années quand j'ai vu les
maires moi j'ai été maire pendant 16 ans
quand j'ai vu les maires être élu
seulement avec 30 ou 35 % de
participation électorale les conseillers
départementaux les conseillers régionaux
avec à peu près aussi peu et puis même à
l'élection présidentielle seulement 70%
de participation ça veut dire qu'on a
besoin d'une refondation démocratique
dans notre pays et ça passe par des
méthodes techniques sont probablement
par des modes de scrutin nouveau et le
scrutin proportionnel en est un pour que
chacun sache que quand il va voter
son idée sera représenté à l'assemblée
nationale mais ça passe aussi par une
capacité à associer à concerter à
retrouver un débat apaisé c'est qu'une
société considère que
quand vous ne pensez pas la même chose
que moi votre pensée est légitime quand
même et qu'elle doit pas nécessairement
je veux qu'elle confiait plus le cas
aujourd'hui on est plongé dans la
violence et la violence et le conflit le
l'observation que nous faisons avec tous
les députés modem qui sont aujourd'hui
sur le terrain en train de travailler
c'est qu'au fond on a une campagne atone
mais on a beaucoup de violence dans le
débat public c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
n'admet plus que l'autre puisse avoir un
avis différent de soi or devant les
problèmes qui sont les nôtres les
problèmes géopolitiques les problèmes
européens les problèmes sanitaires des
primes de pouvoir d'achat d'inflation il
faut qu'on puisse trouver des chemins
commun et c'est cette méthode la
composent le président alors cette
méthode et ses annonces parmi les
réactions il ya sept de la cgt qu'on a
noté
qu'ils ne supportent pas précisément
cette référence au conseil national de
la résistance parce qu'à l'époque
c'était les nationalisations c'était la
sécurité sociale est aujourd'hui celle
annonce d'une réforme des retraites en
2023 même dit le président dès 2023 et
là il ya l'impression d'un passage en
force qui correspond pas aux valeurs du
conseil national la résistance rôle-clé
d'héritage du conseil national de la
résistance c'est un héritage qui
appartient à tout le monde dans la
république qu'on soit de droite du
centre et c'était rue d'auge un progrès
social alors que la cgt dit c'est plutôt
direction que nous devons porter touche
c'est comment on protège le modèle
social français le modèle social
français c'est le système de retraite
par répartition qui nous faut
effectivement sauver c'est pour ça qu'il
ya besoin de faire la réforme des
retraites et d'europe et celle âge et de
ses scpi est ce qu'on n'est pas capable
dans ce pays où on a l'impression que on
a besoin de plus de moyens à l'école on
n'a plus besoin de plus de moyens à
l'hôpital on a besoin de plus de moyens
dans la justice on a besoin de plus de
moyens de dans les mairies sur les
territoires est-ce qu'on peut pas
accepter de travailler tous un peu plus
visiblement pour une majorité de voir le
français d'ailleurs non et il ya bien un
travail de conviction à faire penser
quand même d'abord il faut avoir il faut
pas faire de démagogie même si on est en
période électorale il faut se dire que
cette réforme des retraites il faut la
penser d'abord finalement par une voix
qui avait été montrée par le conseil
national de la résistance et celle des
progrès sociaux qu'est ce qu'on fait en
matière de carrière l'ont qu'est ce
qu'on fait en matière de ni bilité
qu'est ce qu'on fait en matière de
formation professionnelle tout au long
de la vie pour qu'on puisse changer de
métier pour aller vers des métiers moins
pénible au cours de la vie qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour l'emploi des seniors
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour la
transmission en fin de carrière où on a
accumulé une expérience qu'on doit
transmettre aux générations futures est
en fin de carrière travailler un peu
moins et transmettre un peu plus on part
de ses progrès sociaux à faire là on y
ajoute la dépendance parce que les
retraités vivent de plus en plus
longtemps et tant mieux tant mieux c'est
une chance formidable pour un pays mais
il faut qu'on puisse traiter la
dépendance dans des conditions dignes et
ben moi j'accepte volontiers acte ou
dans des métiers qui sont pas pénible
comme le mien de travailler une année où
une année et demie de plus et là dans la
korité des métiers au sein de la
majorité des métiers les gens veulent
partir plus tôt et là clairement il ya
un travail de conviction à faire
d'autant que vous avez des candidats des
concurrents comme jean luc mélenchon et
ses amis de la gauche qui propose la
retraite à 60 ans c'est un vrai argument
oui oui maintenant on a bien compris que
jean luc mélenchon s'étaient de la
retraite à 60 ans l'augmentation du smic
le blocage des prix ce pour la mener
campagne électorale les gens vous
interpelle si on la regrette dire une
chose très juste en fait il va falloir
convaincre
je veux pas convaincre des gens qui sont
pas d'accord avec nous qu'il faut
absolument penser comme nous le sujet
n'est pas celui-là c'est comment on va
repenser la manière de travailler que ça
va au cours d'une vie il ya des moments
où on peut travailler un peu plus il ya
des moments où doit travailler un peu
moins parce qu'on a des enfants parce
qu'on a des parents en grand âge à
accompagner parce que on a une personne
handicapée dans notre vie donc il faut
s'occuper également
qu'on puisse choisir le temps de travail
dans sa semaine au cours de la vie et
que en fin de carrière on puisse choisir
de travailler un peu moins de
transmettre un peu plus et qu'on se
donne tous la chance dans la génération
qui vient aujourd'hui sur le marché du
travail d'avoir trop quatre métiers
différents c'est ça l'évolution est donc
faux parce convainc que qu'au moment de
germinal on doit tous travailler à la
mine deux années de plus ou trois années
de plus dans la vie c'est savoir comment
on organise la société mille plein
emploi et de l'inflation avec des
progrès sociaux est ce que vous au modem
si ça coince lors de ce conseil national
de la refondation ou cette question sera
évidemment mises sur la table il faut
savoir adapter voir reculer par exemple
sur la limite d'âge à 65 ans disent
c'est une question simple enfin ça va de
soi et c'est même ce qu'elle dit et le
président de la république et la
première ministre
ils ont considéré qu'il n'y avait pas de
totem sur l'âge savez on va décider des
progrès sociaux qu'il faut faire
ensemble et à partir de là on
déterminera n'gbo n'a pas nécessaire ses
65 ans est entré dans les esprits je
veux juste rappeler quelque chose l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite
aujourd'hui c'est 62 ans la réalité du
départ à la retraite c'est 60 3 ans et
demi parce que la retraite
complémentaire obligatoire décidée par
les syndicats dont la cgt c'est
précisément 63 ans et donc ne faisons
pas une obsession sur l'âge et regardons
les situations individuelles je crois
qu'une bonne protection sociale au 21ème
siècle c'est une situation c'est une
protection qui s'adapte aux situations
de chacun dans cette interview le
président s'en prend aussi aux
oppositions qu'il accuse le site de
désordre et de soumission en préparant
des alliances stratégiques avec
éventuellement la rue s'il vise le
rassemblement national et la france
insoumise et il dit que jean luc
mélenchon c'est pas un soupçon c'est une
fascination jean luc mélenchon pour
voulait dire mais protéines depuis des
mois et des mois qu'il sent ils s'en
défendent et et marine le pen et jean
luc mélenchon en tout cas le président
d'islande et c'est bien la vie politique
vous pouvez retrouver les images il dure
que jean luc mélenchon ne peut pas
imposer sa nomination au président que
c'est le président qui doit choisir
aucun parti politique ne peut imposer un
an président est ce que veut lui aussi
finalement n'abuse pas de la
constitution parce que s'il ya une
majorité
pour jean luc mélenchon il n'aura pas
vraiment beaucoup de choix lequel c'est
le mot je pense qu'il faut pas quand on
perd une élection essayé d'organiser une
démocratie parallèle
quand on perd l'élection présidentielle
on essaie de se faire élire premier
ministre sans pour autant être candidat
aux élections et puis on voit bien au
sein de la france un soumises
aujourd'hui parce que la nuque ce n'est
pas autre chose que la france a soumis
ce cas qui a pris l'ensemble du
leadership sur la gauche et puis on
organise aussi une sorte de parlement
j'ai vu ça récemment parce que si jamais
on n'était pas majorité au parlement ont
fait aussi un parlement parallèle et
puis on aurait organisé les enquêtes
permet juste de vous reposer la question
quand lionel jospin a gagné les
élections législatives en 1997 jacques
chirac n'a eu d'autre choix que de
nommer lionel jospin à matignon donc
quelque part quel autre choix aurait
monsieur macron si je suis devant vous
aujourd'hui c'est précisément pour qui
manuel maquereau et le choix de ne pas
choisir jean luc mélenchon roi otto
couronné de cette nouvelle gauche
parallèle parce que vous pensez qu'il
n'est pas en mesure aujourd'hui de
gagner les élections les partis parce
que je pense il apporte aujourd'hui
des réponses qui sont celles du passé
c'est ce qu'ils proposent c'est le
programme du parti communiste de 1977
qui a été appliquée au début du cep du
premier septennat de françois mitterrand
et deux ans après c'était le tournant de
la rigueur et c'était le début des
nouveaux pauvres en france c'est parce
que je veux pour mon pays le modem est
satisfait de la place qu'il a dans le
nouveau gouvernement je vous pose cette
question j'imagine la réponse de xavier
cinq ministres y en avait deux mains
vous connaissez la réponse que françois
bayrou s'est déjà exprimé sur le sujet
on a de très bons ministres marc fesneau
offre un très bon ministre de
l'agriculture je suis sûr que quand il
va travailler sur le chèque alimentation
il sera capable parce que les députés du
modem souhaite que chaque alimentation
ce soit une arme contre la malbouffe je
suis sûr qu'il va nous aider à faire
bayrou il n'était pas très content
justine bénin il est vrai que sur leur
présentation gouvernement nous avons
sagement évitée une sur-représentation
excessive mérite et ça nous empêchera
pas au parlement parce que ça aussi
c'est la refondation la capacité à mieux
discuter entre gouvernement et parlement
c'est nous et ce n'est clairement plus
des ministres avant les législatives on
espère surtout avoir de l'influencé pour
que l'on réponde touche aux inquiétudes
des français c'est ça l'enjeu des
élections de dimanche prochain on vous
entendu merci patrick mignola président
du groupe modem à l'assemblée nationale
est folle